good morning everyone and welcome to the
european parliament here in strasbourg
parliament's european commission and
council have recently come to an
agreement for the new european um
digital markets act this act puts an end
to the ever increasing dominance of big
tech companies i'm maria from the web
communication team of the parliament and
to discuss these rules i'm joined by the
member of the parliament in charge of
this
legislation at the parliament mr andreas
schwab
welcome i'm maria hello
but before we get underway with the
interview i'd like to remind our
audience possible to my guests in the
next half an hour or so so mr schwab
let's get tons of business
first of all what is the digital markets
act and why does the european union need
one
well um
big tech
social media and all these digital
elements have been made a huge
part of our life in the last 10 years in
the last 15 years but we have also been
seeing a certain number of big problems
one of the problems was and is always
the economic dominance of these
companies and for this we have european
competition policy european commission
can act to fix specific problems but the
problem here was that it has taken too
much time so what we wanted was a tool
that can be used very quickly because
the digital markets are so fast can be
used very quickly to fix problems
already at an early moment and that's
what we did with the digital markets act
we have so so to say create the change
of burden of proof rule so that big tech
has to prove at the beginning if there
is a dangerous development and not the
commission has to run behind them for
years and to prove them in court at the
end that there was something so we have
improved the situation for authorities
to act with speed okay
so as you're explaining the digital
market act will ban certain practices
used by big tech companies acting as
gatekeepers but which companies can be
designated as such as such gatekeepers
that's a that's a good question
but it's a bit difficult to to say today
because what will happen tomorrow we
don't know exactly
whatever where most of the consumers
have to be an app store for example if
you have a mobile phone like a
smartphone today you have to go through
so at the app stores of apple and of
google you have to be there you cannot
avoid
this
other elements might be the search
engines and for these companies that
control these bottlenecks they are
considered gatekeepers and so far it's
google apple amazon facebook and
microsoft probably tik tok and uh maybe
also other chinese or european companies
basis of the turnover
um and of the basis of the market
capitalization so two objective facts
that the european commission has to take
into account when assessing the
situation so so far there are no
european companies that fall under this
category well we don't know really if
the stock markets grow fastly it can be
well done that there is also for example
booking or maybe salando but it will
depend on the number of users on the on
the market capitalization on the
turnover and that will be decided by the
european commission when using this law
to go behind them receiving a lot of
extremely negative publicity over the
last years big tech companies have
shaped the european digital
landscape positive ways so however they
have a dominant position between
businesses and consumers then can you
give some example of the distance
well i mean the european commission has
gone for a certain number of apple that
i've always chosen
is the app which is not such of
importance there is one app which is
called disconnect
and this app um shows you how you are
tracked
so
you see who is following you when you're
online
and this app is available only in the
app store of apple but not in the app
store of google because google is saying
that android is based on advertising and
if the advertising is shown to the user
it might have a negative impact and
therefore this app has not been
available on android app store but on
apple and we say no all apps have to be
available on all app stores the right
digital companies especially also the
big ones have helped a lot to make our
daily life easier also that you can meet
today maria here with users on facebook
is a pleasure and it's something that is
only possible because of these companies
but these positive elements
unfortunately have also some negative
effects on the market as we would like
them to do and to create that balance in
the markets again
we also wanted to do the digital markets
act
and